l'atelier des p'tits princes donc c'est
une c'est un groupe de quatorze
bénévoles et nous allons
deux fois par semaine le mercredi et le
vendredi voir les enfants qui sont
hospitalisés
la tinée l'équipe passe sous peu
les enfants qui sont malades de cancer
organisée au service chd de bellepierre
l'atelier petit prince étant les
ateliers et une des activités de notre
comité et offre donc auprès des malades
et de leurs familles les enfants en
particulier et bien des services de
l'accompagnement de l' écoute et
participe avec eux à 7 un nombre
d'activités pour animer la vie des
enfants lorsqu'ils traversent la maladie
quand nous sommes avec les enfants va
nous jouons nous faisons la lecture
nous essayons de leur donner la
possibilité d'être rom quelques heures
des enfants comme tous les autres
bisoli un petit peu
seulement leur douleur
leur fatigue et même leur solitude notre
guide nous a aidés déjà à exister encore
plus l'enfant elle pense à au moins il
ya des gens qui font ça aide parce que
j'avais l'impression d'être oubliés à
nice est malade
ce camarade avant
puis la maladie de pompe des petits
princes d'un vol aider à surmonter et
tous ces problèmes
las de solitude et tout est donc elle se
trouve et se retrouver parmi ces enfants
malades et des petites phrases et puis
bon mais ça permettait de sentir qu'elle
existait elle existe et elle est
toujours là l'association les aide à
oublier ce qu'ils sont malades
nous ça nous permet aussi de de souffler
un petit peu quand tu viens pour
de parano
et
mais c'est un prof beaucoup de choses
sauf les enfants sentent mieux qu'ils
sont en traitement de jours on essayait
de faire des manifs telle manifestation
c'est à dire 2
des sorties
pique nique des
sorti sur le grand bleu
nous avons aussi parallèlement le noël
de propre
noël par part
j'en prends qui sont hospitalisés
et les enfants qui peuvent sortis
les deux chefs
parallèlement signaux faisant des
voyages quand on a envie de placer
l'argent en fait des voyages on a déjà
fait quatre voyages en vacances de neige
chaque fois pour 10 enfants accompagnés
les vols dans le sens du service et
revenons à tous un lissage des témoins
tout d'abord de féliciter les artistes
pour l'excellent travail réalisé et à
leur bel élan de solidarité
andré malraux disait que l'un est plus
court chemin de l'homme à l'homme n'en
démord de ce monde et un groupe d'amis
de copains le peintre et on s'est dit on
va faire une bonne action mais la vente
de ses toiles
à l'été l'association
de faire cette action pour les enfants
et ça m'a vraiment motivé pour peindre
et voilà si haut si ça peut amener un
sourire à quelques temps ci
par l'intermédiaire des fonds collectés
on peut leur apporter des distractions
ou un petit wazir c'est toujours ça de
gagné
voilà